good morning good morning so i'm harold
from research
and i'm going to give an overview of the
kind of work we do at comma
so our stated goal at coma is to
build a superhuman driving agent
which is basically a level five
self-driving car
and i'll talk about the way we're trying
to achieve that
first i'm gonna
test my uh
pointers
right that works
hmm
oh
that's something so before we can talk
about how to build a self-driving car
it's important that we have a very clear
definition of what it is that we're
trying to achieve
so to build a real self-driving car i
think
the first obvious thing we want is that
it doesn't crash
crashing would be bad
we can expect it to never crash because
that's very difficult so
crashing less than an average human i
think is
a good minimum goal
another problem is that you also want to
get you somewhere
if it doesn't get you anywhere it's not
that practical
and for it to be really useful we wanted
to drive on basically all the roads that
a human would have no problem navigating
so just your average driver with a
driver's license our self-driving car
should be able to do the same things
it shouldn't oh
i don't know why that happened
it shouldn't have to satisfy it
shouldn't satisfy these things just by
being super slow and avoiding hitting
anything just by driving five miles an
hour so it should be somewhat efficient
so that humans don't get frustrated by
using this
and then the last point's a little bit
more nuanced um we want to build a
self-driving car that doesn't require
any infrastructure at all
what i mean by infrastructure is
we don't want to have to change the lane
lines or the road or change the traffic
signs and change the traffic lights also
it appeals a little bit more to our
self-driving system
we want something that works
exactly on the roads that humans can
drive on now
if it can't do that you're basically
just building a train in a slightly
different format so no infrastructure
okay
so first we'll think about the the
classical approach that people use when
building a self-driving car
it's kind of seen generally as a
robotics problem where you have some
environment in this case you've got the
road and then you've got a whole bunch
of sensors that tell you things about
this environment you've got cameras
radars some cases lidar imus
and all these sensors go into some
perception layer
this perception layer can
analyze what these sensors are doing and
can process it in some way in many cases
you have machine learning models running
that will
parse the camera data and tell us some
things about maybe where are the lane
lines where the other cars where
pedestrians
all this information then produces some
perception output which is a list of
things that you think might be relevant
for driving which is like we said lane
lines where everything is where the
people are where the traffic lights
and then this would go into another
layer which is the planning layer
the planning layer is generally some
kind of hard-coded optimizer that tries
to optimize several different goals
which is like don't hit things try to
get somewhere follow some traffic rules
and then the planning layer outputs some
trajectory that you expect the car to
drive
which is then executed by some kind of
control system robert talked earlier
about what that control system kind of
looks like and here we can see the
steering wheel turning
so we'll look a little bit more into
what one of those perception systems
would be here are some examples of
things people use for self-driving cars
so you've got a machine learning model
that just looks at the video of the road
and it's labeling all these things that
might be relevant which is like cars
people
traffic lights it's probably also you've
got systems that label all the lane
lines and the sidewalks it's laboring
the bus is a different thing as a car
and then you can compile all this
information together with some other
sensors maybe like lidar into this 3d
representation of the world where you've
got all these cars all these lane lines
you know where you are and you know kind
of
some some version of what the
environment looks like
once you have this perception output
let's go back one
i can
oh yeah there we go
so we have just a classical planning
layer you'd have some objectives that
you try to stay so like stay in your
lane don't hit other things don't hit
cars stop at traffic lights and let's
give an example here for this scene
how do we do that well it's pretty easy
right you just drive straight stay away
from the other cars don't don't try to
go over the lane lines so this seems
pretty easy to write an optimizer that
can satisfy those requirements
then we go to the
next scenario
here this is a little bit more
complicated
let's go back
where we have
an intersection
and
let's say we want to turn left at this
next intersection
now you're trying not to hit things
you're trying to stay in lanes
and you're trying to stop the traffic
lights now this doesn't seem like much
of a problem the light's green so you
can drive through the intersection that
lane's open so you can just go over
there drive there and then you turn left
at the next intersection that doesn't
seem that hard we can write some code
that does that
but if we zoom out a little bit in this
scene
i'm really confused by which button does
which on my clicker
the top one goes forward
oh there we go all right so we zoom out
a little bit in this scene and there's a
pedestrian standing on the crosswalk now
this person looks like he's paying
attention and it doesn't look like he's
going to cross if there was a car
driving but we still kind of want to
keep a safe distance you know our
optimizer has a target which is don't
hit people so we try to keep some
distance from all the pedestrians that
we're trying to avoid but what does that
actually mean
you want to drive in this left lane you
want to keep some distance from this
person but you also want to stay in the
lane so what's the compromise like are
you going to drive in the middle of this
lane or are you going to drive a little
offset
there starts to be a lot of these
competing costs in this optimizer and it
has to be very confusing how you tune
this to get a desirable trajectory
personally i would just drive in the
left lane and stay a little bit away
from this person and that'd be fine
but it's hard to actually implement
these compromises correctly
and then if we change the scene a little
bit
imagine it's a child that just dropped
his ball
for me this would completely change
things i would not go in that lane and
i'd keep way more distance but this
introduces a new problem which is that
our perception layer doesn't output
whether this is a child or a normal
pedestrian or a child that's holding a
ball or just dropped a ball
so now it's kind of unclear how we can
write policy that deals with pedestrians
correctly because pedestrians can
encompass all these different things and
the more of these kind of more
complicated scenes we look at the more
and more we run into these edge cases
that we really have no idea how to deal
with
so that's the classical approach
it honestly seems like the back button
works and all the other ones don't
so the flaws with this classical
approach are that
you require machine learning models that
do perception based on some camera
stream or some lidar stream and
generally these are hand labeled that's
very resource intensive and not very
practical
the planners are some hard-coded
optimizer logic which has generally has
to have code for a whole variety of
different scenes and environments and
this list grows and grows as your system
becomes more and more capable and has
some unbounded complexity
and then there's the other problem which
is that the planners need to take in
information from the perception model
and any list of things that we can come
up with that we think will be good
enough for the planner tends to be
incomplete we always run into some new
edge cases and actually need to add new
information and this list of things the
perception model needs to output also
grows endlessly
so the result is you have this stack
which is
massively complicated impossible to
maintain
and this is why you see many
self-driving car companies that use this
approach make a lot of progress for a
few years and then they start to
stagnate because they're working on this
huge stack that is so difficult to alter
because of how complex and intricate it
is
so what can we do
a friend of mine used to say
every time you get in a car you show it
how to drive
the problem is is that it forgets
and this brings up a very powerful idea
humans don't drive by memorizing some
very long list of rules of how to act in
every environment
instead they learn some basic traffic
laws maybe but in general they observe
how other people drive they observe how
their teachers drive and from that they
learn how to operate a car
so we can very easily collect data of
humans driving
so how can we
leverage that in the same way that a
human would
to
teach the system about how driving on a
road
works so we call this an end-to-end
approach we can just build machine
learning models that take in some raw
sensor data like video or other sensors
and can immediately just say drive like
that
so it's kind of like having
video and asking a human based on this
video where would you drive
so we can very easily collect this data
set
and then we can show the model where the
human drove and have it
predict predict that and then you have
this system that will tell you where
things humans would have driven and it's
actually a very powerful idea because
when you have a data set of thousands of
users then the model will predict where
things thousands of users would all
predict on driving together so it's kind
of some consensus approach which can be
much more robust than just asking a
single person where they would drive
and what's really powerful about end to
end is that
all you need to make it handle
more complex scenarios
is to make the models bigger give it
more data
and it will just become better and
understand more it doesn't require more
code it doesn't require hand tuning some
things and it doesn't require adding
extra logic for every new scenario we
support all we need is bigger models and
more data
so given that we can redraw the diagram
and look at the new approach
so
we've deleted the perception layer all
we have is raw sensor data it goes into
some big planning machine learning model
that outputs where it wants to drive
and then that gets sent to some controls
interface and operates the vehicle it's
now much simpler and should be far more
scalable to
actually dealing with the huge variety
of complex situations that appear on the
road
so
to start
we need data and we need a lot of it so
that the machine can learn from it
openpilot collects data from all over
the world in one minute chunks
we collect currently over 100 000
minutes a day
collectively it's over 50 million miles
of data collected
and that equates to a few full lifetimes
of driving
humans can learn how to drive in a few
lifetimes so it doesn't seem
unreasonable to expect that under some
conditions a machine learning model can
too
on the right you can see just a couple
weeks of data collection from the united
states you see we have a
pretty widespread
data collection across the entire
country
i think there's some ai in this clicker
oh i see
all right let's go oh
maybe i should just stop for a while and
let it catch up
okay this is oh that's the one i wanted
that's the one i want great
so just to give some examples of how
really diverse this data set is i just
made this quick tool where you can click
on the map and it'll show you some video
that's the closest i picked some places
i thought would look cool so we've got
the golden gate bridge utah
joshua tree national park
san francisco bay bridge
new york city the colorado mountains
and so when it's exposed to all these
scenes our model can learn about how
driving works in all these different
environments
this is some international data we've
got thailand
some rural roads in scotland
nigeria belgium singapore
taiwan
so you can see driving is really
different in all these scenarios and
it's very important that we have this
massive amount of diversity in the data
set so the human so the machine can
start to understand what's different
between driving on some farm road in
scotland where you drive on the left and
driving on some you know cobblestone
street in belgium
so we've got the data
and now we want to start thinking about
how we train this model
we want to clearly define what the
output of the model will be
we talked previously about how the model
is going to output some path of where to
drive this path is going to be in meters
it's going to say over the next 50
meters you know turn a few meters left
or turn a few meters right and after
that straighten out
getting this information about where a
human drove in this representation
for all the video we have is actually
not trivial we need a localizer to do
this
so a localizer answers the question
where am i right now
where am i looking where am i going and
where did i go
once we can answer those questions we
can then generate the ground truth for
our machine learning models
on the right here you can just see some
satellite view overlaid with
some images we use to represent cameras
of video we've taken so there's just
four parallel lanes somewhere in the bay
area
so to build a localizer
we start with gps or if you want to call
all those constellations
including the chinese and the europeans
who call it gnss
gps doesn't exactly tell you where you
are it has these satellites orbiting
around the world
and it tells you kind of how far away
every satellite is from you if you know
that and you know where the satellites
are you can then kind of estimate where
you are and this is what most gps
receivers do the thing is they use
pretty simple algorithms with not that
much compute to do that when satellites
tell you how far away they are there's a
lot of error in this measurement
it can be influenced by the humidity of
the atmosphere by the relativity errors
in the satellite's atomic clocks it can
be influenced by things in the
just ionization in the atmosphere and so
we can get quite a bit more accurate
results if we just take these raw
measurements and do our own processing
so we built an open source project
called leica which is capable of doing
all this processing and we can get much
more accurate results one of the cool
things that we can do by having our own
library is we also get the doppler
shifts to every satellite at doppler
shifts you can measure the difference in
frequency that you're seeing from a
satellite and it will tell you the
relative speed of your receiver to the
satellite and this actually gives you
such accurate speed readings that the
gps gives you far better speed readings
than the speedometer of your car
so this is very useful for the kind of
localization we're trying to do
one of the examples of things like i can
do is if there's activity on the surface
of the sun this ionizes the earth's
atmosphere and can cause a few meters of
localization error in any normal gps
receiver
we can download some reports from nasa
that tell us about the solar activity
and compensate accordingly making our
localizer even more accurate
so we've got raw gps measurements that
we process a little bit massage a little
bit to get low errors and
we can use that to get a location
and to get speed but it doesn't tell you
where you're looking
it just tells you the position not the
orientation
another problem is that gps is great but
not always when you're under trees in a
tunnel in a parking garage gps either
works worse or not at all
so to be able to have ground truth in
all driving scenes
we want to
have a system that always works so it
needs to work when gps is spotty and
sometimes even when gps is not there at
all for intermittent periods of time
so we want to do sensor fusion with
redundant sensors
we made an open source project to do
this it's called red nose and it's a
pretty large kalman filter which is a
type of optimization filter that takes
in all these different measurements
including gps
and will output its best estimate of
where you are and the orientation of
your vehicle
one of the so we use imu data here
speedometer data um but the most
important is actually uh camera data so
we can look at the video of uh of the
dash cam and we can see how things are
moving in the scene and we can track
those with things called orb features
and we can use those
pieces of information in our in our
sensor fusion system and it'll give us
accurate information about not only
where we're going but also what
orientation we have how the car is
turning
if you have
very accurate localization of both your
orientation and position across many
frames you can start to stitch things
together so here you can see kind of a
cool example of how well our localizer
works we take all these points that it's
seeing while driving along this road and
you project them all down and see this
beautiful top-down view of you passing
an exit but staying in your lane
and
this localized very accurate and that's
great but the most important thing about
it is that it is robust
oh no no no
it needs to work in all the situations
we want to expect our car to drive which
is all of them
so
it needs to work when the scene is dark
when there's not many things going on
not many features uh to tell you about
where you're going in this case we still
have a sign
and but once you pass the sign really
you've just got a couple lines on the
road and this can really confuse the
camera odometry system
this is actually an example of a bug we
had only a few releases ago where if the
lines were continuous then it would
match features to itself and get super
confused and start cutting the turn but
that's now been fixed and so so far the
system has become incredibly robust
so now we've got ground truth we know
where the human drove for all this video
we have so all we have to do is we train
a neural network that takes in a couple
of video a couple of frames from the
video we just use two
and predicts a path of where a human
would have driven in that situation here
you can see the system training it's a
little bit noisy at the end but it's
already getting right that you have to
go mostly straight
the model we actually use is an
efficient net b2
takes in the images here which are that
size and then goes to some head and
outputs this path
no no no
okay
so we've trained our machine learning
model
and
now it's time to find out whether it
works
so generally in machine learning you
have some training set of data
that you've worked on
and then you've got some other data that
you keep separate to test on just to
make sure that it's not over fitting so
we've got all these examples from our
validation set
and we look at them it looks pretty cool
we've got some lane lines in there as
well that was easy to do so we just
added those and you can see it turns
turns there you can see it even gets the
3d parts pretty pretty nicely here it's
pretty things going uphill
and
i'm going over a crest of a hill over
there but in general this looks pretty
good this
looks like what i would have labeled if
i were to say where to drive
so we're ready to try it out on a car so
we take this model we implement it
we make it so that its output is
executed by controls
and
it doesn't work at all we drive on it it
completely drifts out of the lane almost
immediately
so there's this quote about software
engineering that i think is really
applicable we do these things not
because they're easy but because we
thought they would be easy
and so this applies here too
but this brings us to
what can we do now we thought it would
work
it looked like it worked on the data we
tried it
but
in the real world it fails completely
we could keep trying things and then try
it on a car but this is very time
consuming and gives us a very very slow
iteration speed
so
we want to have some way to test it
online from offline from our desks
before we go out and try it on a real
car again
to do this we would need a simulator so
that
in the simulator the model can predict
where it wants to drive we can have some
simulated control system execute on that
trajectory and we can then see how it
behaves
hopefully if the model is driving on its
own path and this is simulated in full
rollout we should start to see similar
results we saw in the real world
so
what kind of simulator can we use
um you can use things like gta 5 or
carla or truck simulator
i mean there's roads there and they look
kind of all right
but the problem you get with those kind
of simulators is very similar to what we
talked about at the beginning the amount
of environments and scenarios one of
those simulators can stimulate is always
going to be limited to the amount of
scenarios you engineered into it it's
never going to capture the full
diversity of human driving
if you want a self-driving system that
can work in nigeria or in the country
roads of scotland you also need a
simulator that can represent that
otherwise if it fails there wouldn't we
never know about it
so we want to build a simulator that is
based off real data and can simulate the
entire spectrum of our data set
so we use a little bit of a trick which
is you just take video and you can just
warp it a little bit left and right make
it appear as though you're driving in a
different location than you actually did
you can see as it's moving around in the
simulator that things are warping a
little bit
and obviously if you go very far from
where the video was taken there'll be
nothing left
but this simple trick seems to be good
enough to do some simple simulations
and those simulations tend to be good
enough
so
let's try the system we just trained in
one of these simulators and see what
happens
so on top we see we just have this
segment of driving down a road behind a
truck and we have the model that
predicts your path and we try to execute
that plan you can see it kind of already
starts to drift out a little bit but in
reality it started to drift out much
much much quicker than that
and then we realized this is because in
the real world there's a lot of
disturbances that act upon the car
there's little bumps in the road
the tires aren't perfectly aligned
and there's things like wind gusts and
all these things push the car around a
little bit in a way that
the model didn't want it to so we can
simulate those disturbances too and this
is what you see in the bottom frame and
you see it drifts out in a matter of a
few seconds this is exactly what we saw
in the real world
so trying to understand what is actually
happening and why
just having the model predict what it
thinks a human would have done in this
situation isn't enough it's kind of
difficult
and something we argue about a lot and
it's kind of is worth the whole
discussion in itself but i'll try to
give as clear of an explanation as i can
which is
imagine the car is on the right of this
lane so it's not perfectly centered
what would a human do in that situation
you could imagine that the human would
probably correct and go back to the
center of the lane
and this is probably true
but
when would the human correct
you can see here it tries to correct a
little bit at the end but in the
beginning it still goes straight
so if that's what's happening and you
have this car at time t0 which predicts
to go straight and then recover
then
tells the controls to do this
it goes straight
and it's still in the same position in
the lane and you ask it again what would
a human in this case but nothing has
changed so it answers the question in
exactly the same way again it says go
straight and eventually recover
and if we run this in a loop the system
never recovers it keeps predicting just
go straight for now and at some point
recover because that's what a human
would have done
but with nothing keeping track upon the
fact that it's never actually executing
recoveries that it had in mind it just
continues to
accumulate error and if there's any
amount of disturbance like wind pushing
this to the right it'll just drift out
of the lane
and so this is what we see in the real
world and it's also what we see in the
simulator now
oh
almost
so how do we solve this
like we mentioned really the problem is
is that the model is never learning to
recover from mistakes it gets pushed out
of where it wants to be a little bit and
it doesn't recover
so
one of the ways we can solve this is by
training directly in a simulator in the
same simulator we've been talking about
push the model left and right a little
bit introduce these disturbances
and tell the model recover right now
and that's what you can see in these
gifs right here
so we've got the black path is where the
human actually drove in this situation
and we pushed the car around a little
bit and we tell it that's where a human
was driving get back there immediately
and that's what you see the white path
is which the model is predicting so
you're seeing we're pushing the car
around
and the model is seeing that and it's
shifting this path to where the human
was driving
you can see the same in this situation
there's actually
a lot of details involved in getting
training in a simulator like this to
work and that's the culmination of a few
years of worker comma we've got some
more technical write-ups about the
details of that but in essence this is
what it is
so we've got this new solution and we
think it might work
but how do we know if it works we
already talked about the importance of
testing before because we don't want to
test in cars testing in cars is super
time consuming we actually have this
rule at research a coma that testing in
cars is not allowed if you can't
reproduce it on your desk it's probably
not worth looking into
so
we want tests that work completely
offline and give us indications about
how the model will perform in the real
world
everything that we don't track or test
explicitly will probably regress or
break at some point we've experienced
this through a lot of trial and error
and we are now very aware of the fact
that every situation we want to work
correctly needs to be appropriately
tested
so we put them all through a whole
series of tests
give it a little eye exam
so i'll just give some quick examples of
the kind of tests we can run that just
give some indication about what's going
on
the first thing is we can just
ask it the model how fast it's driving
we know how fast the car was driving if
the model doesn't know exactly its own
speed
that's generally an indication of some
kind of failure
we can also
we can check the accuracy of how closely
it's matching the path that the human
was driving how closely it's matching
the predictions of some lane lines if
anything here looks weird or there's a
lot of outliers that's usually an
indication of a failure that we would
want to look into
we also have this simulator
so
we can actually just let the system
drive in simulation and do all kinds of
tests of how it behaves we can introduce
lag in the steering rack and see how it
reacts to that we can introduce
disturbances such as wind we can make
the steering wheel offset pretty large
so that it's just pulling left all the
time and we can see how it reacts to all
these situations and kind of get an idea
of
how it would fail and how many
disturbances are necessary for it to
fail
so we drive the model in simulation on
thousands and thousands of minutes of
driving and we see kind of what the
overall results are we check how often
it deviates from the human path we check
does it cut turns too much does it
overshoot turns too much is it just kind
of too aggressive all the time
and all these things we can find out by
just doing metrics on
thousands and thousands of minutes of
simulated driving
um
so one of the other tests we do is
just check overall
when did the model predict to do
something
that is
completely different from what the human
actually did in this situation so did
the model ever predict something that
looks like a swerve compared to what the
human did
and here's some of those results of
those tests as you can see they're
basically all lane changes
the human made a lane change which is
the white path
and the model predicted to stay in your
lane
this isn't a bad thing but it brings up
this interesting point which is that
we expected the model to always output
the right answer which is what a human
would have done
but that's not there's sometimes there's
more than one correct answer whether or
not you make a lane change both making
the lane change or not making the lane
change is generally acceptable and it's
definitely both safe
so
we need to give them all some context so
that it can
understand how to deal with this
we need to make sure the model
understands where it wants to go so that
i can
make a lane change if it's necessary or
turn right or left if it's necessary
here's some examples of this happening
so you've got a human making a lane
change past this car
and here you've got an intersection
where there's a turn left lane
and there's a go straight lane
and here in this case the person kept
left to make the left turn but might
have just as well just gone straight
so to deal with this problem we just
have like a small set of hand labeled
classes which is you can go straight you
can make a lane change you can keep left
keep right you can turn left turn right
and we label those we give that model
the model that is context so it makes
sure that when the model's making a lane
change it's doing that when it's told to
make a lane change
um
and then that brings us to there's
really only one correct path given this
information
so we fix this problem by labeling that
you'll hear later in in the talks a
little bit more about how exactly we
label that
and so this kind of works
and it more than kind of works this is
an end-to-end system that we've shipped
and since a few months has been running
on open pilot you can go into settings
and disable lane lines and it will just
work completely end-to-end in the way
that we've described this is as far as i
don't know the only kind of end-to-end
self-driving system that works at all
and it's definitely the only one that
you can experience
so
i'll just go through some quick
examples of
kind of the power of this end-to-end
approach and things that it allows us to
do
i think the button's sticky i think
that's what's going on
oh oh did i do that
wrong talk
but the clicker definitely has a mind of
its own
anyway so
uh quickly i'll give some examples of
lane changes which are one of the things
that's possible with this end-to-end
thing we can we've told the model about
lane changes during training
and so
we can also tell her to do a lane change
like a human would
i'll take a drink break while we're
oh we're taking a break anyway
the lane changes are too good yeah
it's trying to keep it a secret
trust me the lane changes are going to
be worth it when they're finally
revealed
[Music]
yeah we can we can talk about it in the
q a as well but uh
i will take a short break everyone can
think about the questions they're going
to ask later
i guess this is kind of a good place to
take a break that was how we build it
and then we have the grand reveal of the
results
okay i can take some questions right now
yeah we'll do a couple questions until
we've got the
laneless results
model training takes a long time
[Laughter]
yeah somebody's trying to get the gpus
up and running
any questions
sure so um
i saw on the slide you had an efficient
net and then a fully connected layer
and that corresponded to um vision and
planning could you go a little bit more
into um
like
are they separated or are they all
trained at once
um is there any separate training of
those two model components uh no it's
just uh it's just architectural
separation so you've got the convnet
which is so the b2 is fully calm and
then you've got some dense layers on the
bottom but it's all trained together how
many parameters on the bottom versus the
the top i don't know or roughly just a
few million in the bottom and i don't
know how much inefficient that is that's
several million too
oh we're back
back back back right so this approach
works
and we've got end-to-end machine
learning working for self-driving
here's uh the first example of this is
we've got end-to-end lane changes
so
this system was never explicitly taught
about lane changes uh lane lines it was
never told that a lane change is
crossing a lane line
we just teach it
these are lane changes that humans did
try to do them like that and in fact
these lane changes will work perfectly
fine if there were no lane lines if this
was snowy or it was just a badly
maintained road lane changes would jerk
would work just as well as they would
for humans
next example is
just driving
lanelessly in a variety of situations
so on the left we've got a road that's
completely snowed in
if there were lane lines we can't see
them
and a classical system would struggle
here there's not really much to go off
you could say that maybe the road ends
there and you try to stay on the road
but
a lane the system can clearly see
this is where a human would have driven
because that's where the tire grooves
are and it can smoothly just do exactly
what a human did
this is the power of the end-to-end
machine learning on the right here you
can see there's a turn to the right and
there's quite a bit of oncoming traffic
that looks quite intimidating and the
lanes model does what a human did which
is cut the turn aggressively to avoid
this oncoming traffic
again these are all just
features that it can learn just by
observing humans we didn't ever tell it
to avoid traffic we didn't ever tell it
to follow the grooves in snow it's just
observing humans and doing what a human
would have done
so what about longitudinal this entire
talk has been talking about lateral
control of the vehicle which is just
controlling the steering wheel
there's more than that to controlling a
vehicle you also need to control the gas
and the brake
we've been working on this for quite a
long time and only the last few months
have we really been able to ship
laneless models that work well
and so that's been the main focus but
all of the lessons we've learned and all
the strategies we apply should work
perfectly fine for controlling
longitudinal as well
so recently we just started working on
that and i'll give some quick examples
of
what some end-to-end longitudinal
features would be
so we've got uh model based fcws that
was shipped a few releases ago
so we can just ask the model a question
you know how humans drive tell me if you
think a human would break in the next
few seconds
and so that's what you see here when the
fcw pops up the model is saying whoa
whoa i think a human would have break
hard here
and so this is shipped in open pilot
if you're engaged and you're in a
situation like this you'll get a warning
from the model saying you might want to
break pretty hard here
here's another example
so again this model we never told it
about
cars explicitly or anything like that
we're just asking it tell us when you
think the model would break when a human
would break hard
another thing we can do is we can ask
the model tell us where you think a
human would stop again that's basically
the same ground truth as the paths we
just check where the velocity becomes
zero and a human driver becomes
stationary for a while
so here you can see the model is
predicting
a stop line which is where the human
would stop right by the red traffic
light
and here you can see it by a stop sign
so this is completely end to end
seeing the traffic lights because it
knows that's where humans generally stop
and the same with the stop sign it's not
explicitly looking at the stop sign it
just looks at the scene and knows a
human would probably stop here
so what's next for comma research
stop lines is one of the features that
we haven't rolled out yet that's the
only thing in the talk that's uh kind of
still experimental we might want to ship
that soon if we can get it to work
pretty well in general we're really just
looking at making this models bigger and
smarter and understand more and more
complex environments so this is going to
keep improving end-to-end lateral
control
and then we also want to move more and
more to end-to-end longitudinal control
currently open pilot still uses lead car
detectors and
just normal acc commands to control the
longitudinal control and we want to
start moving that to exactly the same
full end-to-end architecture we're using
for lateral
questions
[Applause]
guys
sure yeah
um
it is used for
some parameter estimation of the vehicle
controls yeah
i'm not really i'm not sure why that
would be necessary
the model shouldn't require gps for
anything at runtime are you saying
because you want to make a map of this
places to stop or something
right right so we do rely on gps for
ground truthing but like i mentioned we
do support spotty gps and gp and so the
system should work completely without
gps and so currently our data set should
capture all the situations where gps
doesn't work just because if you had gps
40 seconds ago
then that's enough to carry through
through the entire chunk of data we
analyze so that's not another
requirement
i'm going to start with questions down
the row here
i want to ask how you
look at training data and decide this is
good driving and by that i mean what
happens if in your training set uh
you look at night and the driving in the
area of this bar at night after 3 a.m is
kind of weaving all over the place or a
human tends to roll this stop sign
or
uh somebody's just weaving on the
highway or quite frankly you drive like
i do when i'm not driving on open pilot
how do you get rid of all my driving
data and train on the chill people
so we kind of
uh think about it as
you're not just looking at mimicking one
person right we're looking at this whole
data set
and we make the assumption that
when humans make mistakes
they tend to do it in noisy uncorrelated
ways and so if you have a system that
behaves like it would the average or the
median of thousands of different drivers
would that's generally a very good
approach if you ask you know 50 people
to look at a video and exactly what they
would do
the consensus of that should be very
stable and i think good driving
if that ends up that the average driver
is perhaps too aggressive what we want
openpilot to be we can start you know
doing some basic things to differentiate
some aggressiveness and tune it down a
little bit so a little bit more
conservative i can see how that would
work for most things but just how would
you control for saying rolling a stop
sign
uh which quite frankly the average is
going to show that a fair bit
so right now we're just really not at
the stage where it makes sense to think
about things that detailed i think
we first want to get to what an average
human would do and if for some reason we
want the system to behave differently we
can think about that then and there's
some tricks to do some filtering of
certain types of human behaviors but i
think average human behavior would be a
massive victory for the entire
self-driving space
thanks again
question here how do you train out like
unwanted behavior
one thing that they've seen with this
end-to-end approach is sometimes car
tries to follow
what driver in front of you does it kind
of ignores lane lines it just
if that car goes right left it just
follows it
yeah so that's kind of similar to
jason's question and like i said
generally mistakes humans make are very
noisy and uncorrelated and so if you
take the average of lifetimes of
thousands of different humans
the behavior should be very consistent
and should be
pretty desirable
yeah i mean like like i just said i
think uh average human driving would be
a huge victory for the self-driving
space no system in the world is anywhere
close to that so that would still be uh
much better than anything in the world
so in regards to n10 lateral control
if you let's say had a camera on both
sides of your vehicle so you had a wider
field of view and you were training on
that
would the ai
start to learn to move over to the left
side of the lane if there's a semi on
the right side like a human would
assuming there's no car on the left side
or would that kind of get washed out in
the training no i'm pretty sure that
would
consistently i think humans try to keep
distance from cars next to them in
highways and so i'm pretty confident
that model should learn behavior like
that you can actually see
in some cases if there's a semi on the
left side of the lane the end-to-end
planning will deviate slightly
awesome thank you
uh yeah so first of all thanks again for
the presentation super informative and
amazing technology um but um kind of
like inverse to the two bias questions
that came before
um
have you found um
either any places where it's relevant or
where it's useful to have explainability
backwards like if the model does
something that's particularly weird one
time like it swerves out a particular
type of lane or it takes certain types
of exits
um are you able to go back and tell
what influenced the model to actually
behave this way yeah so that's i think a
very interesting question and something
that i when i started working on these
things was much more worried about than
i am now i think generally these models
are seen as kind of these black box
things that can predict behave in
unpredictable or weird ways and there's
no way of explaining it but so far every
case that we've seen of it behaving
something that initially looked weird
we've been very easily able to reproduce
and explain to give one quick example of
an issue we used to have is
everything was fine the roads looked
fine and it would sometimes randomly
start predicting lane lines in the
center of the road
and this was a bit of a mystery for a
while and then you start to look at the
ground truth uh that has you know lane
lines in the middle of the road and you
find there's some person that had like a
fluffy thing at the front of his car
which was kind of colored orange which
was detected as a lane line so this kind
of made it into the data set and then
the model sometimes behaved that way but
so far every single weird behavior we've
seen we've been able to explain
same yeah
what's your intuition on continuously
making use of larger models and keeping
just sort of taking the traditional ml
and just scaling it forward
because in the case of like real like
real world like you have distributional
shifts
in that case examples that occur very
rarely would be it would be unlikely for
the model to make any sort of
generalization on that sort of data so
how do you
sort of augment the data so make use of
examples that occur very rarely
i'd say so far we haven't really seen
much of the issues with that yet if
there have been issues where the model
struggles in rare cases of that
it seems to be that generally the model
is just limited by the quality of our
ground truth if there's you know 0.1 of
data that looks completely broken
because of some bug this will usually
manifest itself in the model not being
that smart in the end and not being able
to see rare cases but as we've improved
the ground truth quality even with the
same size of model we've seen the model
become smarter and smarter and can learn
more and more rare events maybe someday
some kind of sampling would be necessary
but i think so far uh we're making very
good progress without that
yes so my question is uh specifically in
regards to driver alertness
so one of the things that i've noticed
that as i'm driving
there's some scenarios that i run into
that i'm particularly on
high alert so i was wondering if there
was any consideration with a comma team
into developing a predictive model uh
maybe you have different levels of
alertness that that
could either be communicated to the
driver or that the
that you recognize as like high risk
scenarios
yeah so
currently we actually have the model
tell us how likely it thinks that open
pilot would be engaged right now and how
likely it is that a user would take over
from open pilot in the next few seconds
either with the brake pedal or the gas
pedal or with the steering wheel so the
model already completely outputs all
this information um we've thought about
communicating this somehow but just
really haven't gotten around to it but
we do have tons of introspection in
how much confidence the model has in
that the situation is weird or that a
human would start to feel uncomfortable
have you and uh one follow-up question
have you thought about like creating uh
projects for
you know uh kind of like a take home
project type of type of thing for uh
where you could let's say you could
export a csv file and
ask a few questions you know and and ask
someone to like predict to develop a a
model like based on you know 10 data
points or 20 data points that that like
oh
if you if you think this would be more
more likely to be a high impact scenario
so like say for example you could go to
uh uh insurance company look at here are
the top 10
uh reasons for car incidents and then
you could you could you could have like
specific questions based on that so just
like just not entirely sure if i
understand the question well just in the
same sense that you have like um if you
look on the website you had you used to
have the 500 bounty so i was asking like
it would have you
was there any consideration or would you
consider like potentially having
something where you took
um just some general instances and then
you you gave that as a project to the
community that we could potentially work
on i mean if you're talking about
developing on the model that's kind of
infeasible for anyone that doesn't have
access to all the data and all the
infrastructure that we use so
that's not something that's easy to
distribute development on
we got a question upstairs hi
a question regarding the evolution of
this approach i mean
my impression that it can brings you so
far like what you do but in building
like a very nice l tool and keep assist
but at some point you probably want to
go to you know like end to end trained
unprotected left turns and going to the
l4
and can you do you think you can push
this approach where like you may like
use the imaging data and the trajectory
of the actual driver for training or you
will have to do some like paradigm shift
where you now go to zero approach and
like where you have to rewrite the whole
training pipeline
um
so i think in general this end-to-end
training scales
much further than any other approach i
mean you mentioned things like mu0
it might be possible that a distribution
shift of that level is necessary that we
can't use the simulator the way we do
now and need something a little bit more
advanced with some kind of learn
simulator or you know other other more
advanced machine learning techniques
something like that but it's like
ideation it's this is nothing like
roadmap where you think okay i probably
go do it this way like in five years
uh we've got some internal discussions
about that but no nothing concrete okay
cool thanks
great thank you
all right um i screwed up my last
question luckily somebody else asked the
right one so this time i took notes um
so two quick questions and one thought
um first question
do you so with your human example under
crossing do you um
consider the bounding box movement if
you
make sense if not because even tesla i
don't think you didn't do that wait i'm
just looking for where you are actually
oh i'm here oh okay sorry i'm like the
voice so what do you mean by the
bounding box oh yeah if you so your
example of the human on the border
crossing on the lane line crosstalk on
the lane crossing yeah would you
consider the bounding box and the
movement of it like the acceleration or
um what do you mean by bounding or for
predicting well you make the bounding
box of the human you you see that
there's a human there right so you make
a rectangle around here oh okay yeah
like now the movement over time right so
would you consider that for example as
to better predict like with stopping or
going right i'm down the line something
like that no so we don't want to do
anything like that so we really want a
fully end-to-end approach the system
should completely learn that a human
would slow down or avoid a human and
that behavior will come into the
end-to-end system right we never want to
explicitly track these things okay okay
oh okay so that goes with my second that
was the thought like of thinking
differently um instead of like finding
out if it's like a kid or adult you
could like do maybe pose estimation
right like you could um train a model
like using epic mega games um
meta human stuff right right so that's
that's the kind of stuff we want to
avoid we really want a system that is
very simple architecture you take in
training data behave like a human so
that uh we don't have to write any of
these code or scenarios to deal with any
complexity right i figured you could
kind of just make a model that um
extrapolates like the movement right the
skeleton and yeah sure but the problem
is this there's an endless list of these
things right right and it never ends
yeah okay um and then last question um
it's more for me like i work on the vr
operating system kind of thing and the
slam stuff is really not great the open
source stem stuff in some ways um your
system the sensor fusion slam tracking
system would that work also for like
lower velocity and like vr kind of
systems or is it more yes it should
completely work uh so we haven't really
been able to spend much time into
documenting or you know putting effort
into really making this library
accessible but it is open source you can
see how we use it and i think it has a
lot of compelling features compared to
other solutions
great i'm going to move to the back of
the room we'll come back to the front
i feel like we have a lot of questions
down here
hi so you mentioned kind of the machine
learning mantra of more data bigger
models and you've been working with
these models for a while
uh do you have any sort of kind of
estimation of how big these models are
going to have to get in order to reach
that goal of driving as well as a human
or are we not even at the point of
estimating that
um
i think it's difficult to estimate that
but internally we talk a lot about
you know what's what kind of animal
would be able to drive a car um would a
cockroach be able to drive a car
probably not
i think that's kind of the scale that
some of the large models people use
these days are at like insect level
i think pretty confident that like a
bird or or a small mammal would probably
be able to drive a car so if you want to
have some very rough estimation i think
that that makes sense to think about how
many neurons do these animals have that
seem to be show complex enough behavior
great we also should have plenty of time
for everyone's questions so
hi
um
so you described that the um end-to-end
approach is essentially predicting the
trajectory that the human would take in
the picture right
mm-hmm isn't that strictly speaking not
fully end to end because
fully antenna to me would mean that you
record all of the inputs that the human
took in the car
and then predict those raw inputs from
each frame a number of steps into the
future yes so it's not fully end to end
i think i glossed over that a little bit
too quickly but uh
we still make the separation between
planning and controls uh what you're
saying is you could skip that as well
just take video output the car commands
the problem with that is that it makes
very difficult to abstract different
types of cars so we support all these
different types of cars so we already
need some kind of common interface there
that's one reason the other reason is
some level of introspection is useful if
we're just seeing the steering inputs
and the gas and brake inputs it becomes
harder to see what the model is thinking
and we really don't think that much is
lost in this abstraction layer between
planning and controls uh it seems like
it's reasonable to think that some plan
some trajectory is planned and then you
should just always be able to execute
that with controls i don't think there's
that much nuance
okay we're back here right
similar to a couple questions but
as far as the level five and
uh somebody mentioned the model but i
was curious more on the hardware do you
think
the the camera and the sensors that you
have now is sufficient or
is it going to require like mimicking
more like a human like binocular vision
or
you know
only cameras or is there any kind of
idea of
hardware wise what the future is going
to hold
yeah i think there's some limitations to
the current system and there's some
reliability concerns but
in general this isn't the limiting
factor given the video that the system
is getting it can do much better and
this is true for all self-driving
systems they're limited by the compute
and by
the software not by the sensors
hi uh i'm curious if you all been
thinking about this or if it's even
appropriate using data visualization or
dimensionality reduction techniques to
try to peek into the black box of the
model so to speak a little bit to see
what features of the world your model is
starting to learn and pick out for its
processing
yeah we've done various experiments with
this at some point tried to train the
gans that try to kind of reconstruct
some representation and we can see it
what things things are important and
stuff like that but like i mentioned in
one of the earlier questions we've never
really had issues trying to understand
what the model is doing with just a
little bit of effort we've always very
easily understood why the model is
making a certain mistake and extra
introspection wouldn't really help us
that much if it was necessary we could
build more tools but it's not a huge
part of the way we work right now
hello so a quick question
as you're ingesting data into the
knowledge base are you capturing video
for all active sessions or is it simply
a sampling of the population and then
secondly how does my active session
benefit from the contents of the
knowledge base
i'm not entirely sure what you're asking
so you're just saying is all data being
used to train the model um
no so we do some kind of diverse sample
with some basic logic to enforce some
level of diversity and then we train on
that um if we see
benefits from training on larger data
sets then we can move to larger data
sets but currently that doesn't seem to
be the limiting factor
how do you plan to gather the context of
a curvature
what do you mean by the context of a
curvature
whether that curvature is going to um
say do a full 90 degrees or
what's
i don't see how you can understand the
curvature unless you have a top-down
view
like a map
i mean
you're talking about the ground truth or
how does the model see this um i could
think that you could ground truth and to
win longitudinal by using open street
maps and then using a test track with um
no no so this is all just ground truth
by using a localizer on human data we
know exactly how a human moved through
the world from the localizer and so
that's the ground truth and that's what
we make the model predict
does the localizer see the context of
the curvature like the future of it yes
the view the localizer knows we use the
whole future of the of the drive so we
do we do know that yeah
hey um has this been tested on
pedestrian crossings like does it stop
if someone's crossing the street so we
as i mentioned longitudinal currently in
open pilot isn't that end to end yet um
we've done some basic experimentation
with end-to-end longitudinal and we
haven't gotten that far with it yet it
does react to some things and it doesn't
react to other things we're still
working on that we only just started
really working on end-to-end
longitudinal but i imagine it would
react pretty appropriately once we start
working on it actively
so my question is more related to the
switching of the lanes so does the model
take into account the
the state of the blind spike blind spot
monitoring is that um is that input data
taken into account in the model that's
not taken account into the model i think
open pilot on some cars it will just
prevent you telling the model to lane
change if there is a car in the blind
spot um
yeah
did i have some questions in the middle
all right i'm headed back front
uh this is a question about the
simulator so
you train off policy and this induces
distributional shift and to account for
that you throw in some noise what you do
with your warping uh
for richer more more dynamic multi-agent
scenes like going through an
intersection do you think this approach
will scale uh what will this work and if
not do you have to have a
multi-agent dynamics model
like wave ai where they predict the
trajectories of other agents
uh
yeah i mean well like we were talking
about earlier it's possible that we need
a little bit of a paradigm shift away
from this uh
type of warp simulator that we're using
now but i think just right now it's not
really a limiting factor we have quite a
bit of ways to go and then maybe after
that we can see if there's different
strategies that can simulate some more
dynamics for example
do you guys use some sort of like
self-supervised learning setup like i
guess cathartic and as talk cvpr he
talked about like how tessa's like
building sort of self-label annotation
engine on training
examples where the model didn't predict
was the accuracy of the prediction
wasn't that high do you guys see that as
some sort of
useful
pruning of data
right now we don't use that and i don't
think we have a need for it right now
um so in this new like what would a
human do type of training for your
models um are you still
like hand labeling for like anomalies
right when you have a dog that runs in
the road or maybe an obstruction um
does this new model
remove the the requirement of that like
is there still a use case for comma
pencil
or is that legacy now
um
so comma pencil has a very important use
in the localizer
the localizer assumes that everything in
the video is an enviro static
environment and by how that moves it
knows how its camera is moving
so that doesn't work if you assume that
moving cars and moving pedestrians are
part of the environment so coma pencil
is incredibly important there to filter
out the things that are moving through
the scene which are not static and the
static background which can be used for
localization so common pencil will
always stay for that common pencil also
we get lane lines from that and lead
cars which is currently still used in
open pilot and
we can conceive beings useful for at
least some level of filtering and
introspection forever but it'll just the
policy will rely less and less on these
kind of things as we move forward
um yeah i think someone you touched on a
little bit but um
when your
model is making mistake
i guess i'm just wondering is generally
the confidence high when you're making a
mistake and
is there any kind of approaches that
you're taking
to try to anticipate whether i'm going
to make a mistake or more likely to fail
uh yeah
yeah so uh like i mentioned earlier the
model does predict the likelihood that
it thinks a human would disengage or
take over in the likelihood that you are
engaged it's very rare for the model to
be confident and still make mistakes
generally if that does happen that was
due to some crazy data bug that we've
fixed
i can't remember seeing any cases like
that recently
um this is a bit of a philosophical
question because from
what i've gathered it seems like you
guys are trying to build a model that
behaves like a human more than just like
an object prediction model
what impacts do you think this will have
on agi in the future say like five ten
years from now
um do you think it'll
help out with that at all or do you
think it'll make it more possible
i mean i think this is just a step
towards agi i think this is more you
know
more generic machine learning that will
scale and
sometimes might create superhuman ais
hi uh so first a comment i work at a
wave ai
and we have a end-to-end lateral and
longitudinal okay right that yours is
the only one you can buy and try
yourself
i appreciate that
uh i don't know if you you could have
seen the videos in the cvpr uh workshop
we had um
i think i've only very briefly seen
things i don't think i really looked
into it um
the question you've mentioned that
most of the stuff you've been doing to
improve the model is improving the
ground truth
but if it's end to end i'm not sure what
ground truth you're improving is that
just failures of the localizer yes
pretty much so the localizer failures uh
they can fail in many different ways
mostly because how much of it relies on
video and you have all these different
types of driving scenes so it didn't
talk that much about the localizer but
we started two open source projects
based on it so it's clearly a big part
of what we do i probably spent
two two to three years really iterating
through the localizer making sure that
it's robust you have you know other slam
systems like orpslam
stuff like that that is very accurate
and works most of the time but they tend
to fail
in rare cases which are still not that
rare and need to be fixed so we spend a
lot of time working through that thanks
we've got another question upstairs
oh hey i'm just curious if
the self-driving models that you're
using primarily seem to be used on
highways and i think of
driving in general to kind of really be
split into highway driving and sort of
city driving with stop signs and people
and stuff like that and i see those as
two kind of distinct problems
do you think that the models that you're
building now
actually can work safely in city
environments or do you see any
challenges looking ahead to level five
in that regard
so
we currently focus on highway driving
just because it's the most useful we
want to make self-driving cars but we do
want to ship cool and useful things
along the way
i don't think there's anything in this
strategy that's inherently limited to
highway driving or any specific scenes i
think it will scale perfectly fine but
it is significantly harder to drive in
the city i think than on highways
hello
i have a bit of an open-ended question
do you guys see like any differences in
the average
of the way that people drive in like
tijuana
and like la and san diego
i can't say i've ever looked at the
differences between cities
but there's certainly a difference
between continents
uh hi i have a question since you say
you uh
finally like uh let let a human kind of
teach the agent to learn how to drive so
when is the day uh come plan to let us
teach it when not working
i mean implicitly that already happens
because
when a user disengages from the system
that's a signal that the user wasn't
happy with the way it works so
there's already this kind of feedback
loop we have very good ground truth for
you know when a user didn't think the
model should drive so we actually have
very accurate
metrics on how confident people are and
what it's doing
we're back here
hey harold
um in your blog posts on lateral
planning you talk about ways that the
model will cheat in the simulations
could you go through some of the ways
that you all detect and
mitigate against the model cheating um
so just quickly on that um
when we move around in the simulator the
image warps and this can be detected by
the model which is what the cheating is
so one of the ways we can detect that is
by introducing
warp without
actually having real data so we can have
fake data introduce warp and seeing if
the model reacts and so we have tools
like that that allow us to measure some
level of cheating and we had some
introspection into that
great these are our last three right
down here
i wanted to ask how your model training
process scales or doesn't scale and this
is my ignorance on machine learning in
in general when you
iterate on your model are you throwing
away the previous model and starting
again from scratch it like if i had a
new human driver 16 years old and they
had an oops collision they would learn
from that and move on and become a 17
year old driver instead of a 16 year old
driver but
i'm curious if you have to start that
over
and if that has implications for scale
and the the kind of long tail of weird
little problems you have to figure out
to reach true self-driving right so
yeah so that's an interesting question
currently we train everything from
scratch most of the time
it doesn't cost that much time so it's
not really a reason to try to avoid that
maybe in the future the training is so
costly that it makes sense to start
training incrementally
um i don't foresee that happening soon
we don't seem to be that limited by the
size of the models right now but if we
do have to scale the models to get the
performance we want then maybe
incremental learning is what we want to
do
uh yeah um so
uh
i know that you know eventually you want
to get to level five and
you know ideally you would be there
tomorrow
um
and then on the other hand some
companies seem like they'll maybe never
get there like waymo
um
what's like
like what what primarily is influencing
the velocity of your model improvements
right now like what what work inputs uh
do you find are
like the biggest barrier to like getting
to that next major milestone for you
right now
i think if i were to list one limiting
factor it would just be the
infrastructure to test the models in how
well we can predict that they perform so
if we have tests we can run immediately
on a trained model and immediately says
it messes up in these ways and it's good
in these ways then it's very quick to
iterate on that
and i'd say it's building these tests
and building these metrics that is very
time consuming and if you mess it up it
costs even more time because you find
out later and you have to go all the way
back so i'd say the quality of how well
we can evaluate the driving offline with
tests i think is one of the limiting
factors
so you mentioned this bug that you had
with the
mapping continuous lines to themselves
in the visual odometry how did you fix
that bug
so we fixed that bug in particular by
doing some basic filtering on the old
features that are tracked so we do have
a gyroscope which tells you how the car
is turning and we have some gps data
neither of those are accurate enough by
themselves but they're accurate enough
to just do some basic filtering throw
out really bad orb features and then the
ones you have left are good enough to
deal with the rest of it
i'm coming so
harold told you guys a lot of things
today
but there's one thing that he didn't
tell you guys and that
it's his birthday today
[Applause]
so
will you all join me in singing happy
birthday to harold
happy birthday to
you
[Music]
happy birthday to
you
[Applause]
i was gonna try to eat this with my
hands but that seems like a mistake
you